[Announcer] You love everything about Comic-Con.
The superheroes, the cosplay, the awesome lines,
but now there's a new convention
that has all that minus the superheroes and the cosplay.
It's Line-Con.
(audience laughing)
The ultimate convention for line superfans.
From the moment you arrive,
you'll be greeted with a check-in line.
Then a line to collect your badge,
then another line to get a program schedule,
a line for your gift bag,
and a line to get on the escalators
to take you to the convention floor
where you can wait in over 300 other lines.
We've hired TSA officers to guarantee wait times
of four hours and up or buy our VIP package
and receive a not so fast pass
that sends you directly to the back of every line.
Sign up for a workshop
and learn classic line standing techniques.
Straight lines, curvy lines, lines with weird breaks in them
plus there's the people who don't know where the line starts
or catch a panel with people who have waited in line
for Hamilton, the cronut, every pair of new Jordans,
and a keynote with the inventor of the butterfly chair.
Plus, celebrity meet and greet
with famed British line-master Dr. Queue.
Don't get your panties wet ladies,
there's only one restroom, and the line for it is huge.
Plus, be sure to stay for the closing night party
where we'll create the world's largest human linetipede.
(audience groaning)
It's Line-Con, tickets go on sale Monday.
Lines forming now.
(audience applauds and cheers)
I want in on that.
I want in on that linetipede.